I first came in 1993 but I've been
coming ten years in a row now since 2003
well since last century really it's been
a long time I started here to graduate
student working on squidoo
electrophysiology and it's kind of
evolved through the years to now we do
my wife and I come and do high-end
imaging and teaching the courses so has
been quite a long time I've all been
coming to the NBL probably since I was a
postdoc so it's not as a lot nearly as
long as my husband jim has been cut and
I started coming more with him because
he was coming during the summers he
tried to find a way to come and bring
her family so I took the physiology
course back in 2005 and I've been back
every year ever since yeah so this is my
eighth year here like this is my fifth
year first time I came to the MBL was
nineteen eighty-nine to the New England
Society for electron microscopy meeting
I was a master student and I saw Keith
Porter give a talk on the stage of Lily
auditorium so I don't know how many
summers and I think I've been here at
least for a couple days every single
summer since then I think this is around
my seventh year and it's it's really an
incredible honor to be here it's
something where I know lots of people
that are knocking on the door and hoping
to get here and I count myself
incredibly lucky I fell in love with the
MBL as a physiology student in 1998 so I
spent six weeks here and had it in my
head that I really someday imagine
coming back and then serendipitously
through really a chance conversation
with Tim mitchison at ASCD meeting the
opportunity arose to start collaborating
and coming collaborating with scientists
at the MBL who are resident scientist
and then basically i had the opportunity
to start coming in the summer and now
i'm having a hard time imagining life
before i came to MBL in the summer i
took the course ten years ago now and
still maintain collaborations with the
people that I met here because in this
environment with so much science so much
excellent science going on and the
development of
of new techniques cutting-edge
techniques you really get ideas and with
the people that that are here who are
sharing this special summer time and and
those relationships persist and that
really has a powerful impact on on my
research and the research of many others
the level of interaction is way higher
than it is in the research labs so it's
nonstop fully saturating human
scientific interaction and it's like the
probability of the higher the
interaction level the higher the
probability that you'll get more than
one inspiration like coming to teach
because I remember for this short period
each year what fun it is to do research
I get to block everything out and just
think about science I think that the
courses are a great opportunity to
basically interact with students you
basically get input from students and a
lot of times you know their ideas are
they spark new ideas with you and it's a
great opportunity to just get more
feedback i I know how cool it is to take
the course from firsthand experience and
it really really I do strongly believe
that he changed the way I do science I
came here to learn more about biology
and ended up falling in love with cell
biology and in particular the
cytoskeleton so I came to learn a little
bit and I left having completely changed
my life if my life was a mathematical
function the two some two months that I
spent in the physiology course in 1993
was a was a discontinuity or a
singularity that left the shape of my
life being completely different after
the course I've been coming down to the
MBL for three summers as a co-director
of a course and that's been an amazing
experience so the thing I really love
about these courses is that we have a
mixture of students postdocs and faculty
who come from around the world and they
spent three weeks here where they
interact with each other and learn a lot
from the faculty who passed through from
a course but learn a ton from each other
and we learned ton from them too it's
not just about you know the everyday
interactions or we know with the speaker
isn't about you know talking to other
faculty talking to people about the
research is also the fact
you know you get to teach in an
environment where people really think
hard about what you're doing and they
force you to a thing even harder so I i
guess it's also a personal belief that
through teaching one also it gets to
think harder about the problems everyone
is thinking about and try to make
connections that you maybe didn't make
originally I always learn something new
every year I always learn things I never
imagined that I would learn I especially
love teaching because I've learned a lot
from the students I learned more from
the students than from anyone else just
from hearing the research that they're
doing back home and interacting with
them on a day-to-day basis that when
we're trying to do experiments together
they always surprise me with their
ingenuity and I come away with
completely energized and it with a
totally new perspective on on my work I
mean I like coming here because I don't
think I've ever come here and not gotten
a new idea I you know there's so much
going on here I bounced off 10 million
people and I bounced a million ideas off
of people I don't get anything done in a
concrete sense but what I do get is
inspiration and new ideas and that's I
mean that's worth more than you know 100
uninspired experiments for the rest of
the year but the reasons i come here are
partly to do my own experiments with my
own hands which once you become a p.i of
a lab group becomes harder and harder to
get out of the office and at the bench
and here I sit behind a microscope and I
look at real cells growing I do
experiments which gives me just the
thrill for for why I fell in love with
science and I get to rediscover that all
over again myself and just to come down
and almost be a postdoc again to avoid
sitting on seminars and hear what other
people are doing and and i started a new
collaboration before lunch my first day
here so i mean just having those sort of
informal interactions with the new group
of scientists is really energizing and
really recharging and and it's been
awesome i'm hoping i can do this you
know every summer this is impossible
it's been really fantastic you have a
critical mass of people that you would
never have access to anywhere
else and also everyone is very very open
here I mean it's a very open sharing
community in terms of the ideas and the
people you can go to anybody's lab and
ask the questions you see seminars on
things you wouldn't normally go to visit
right here and so it you get many more
ideas so what I would say about coming
here that's so amazing just I can
illustrate with a story I got off the
bus three days ago and between the time
I got off the bus and I got to my house
I ran into three people and I already
had two meetings planned including a
dinner meeting and not somebody I hadn't
met before and we talked in really
amazing science so there's just so many
people here that are off-scale I really
recharge my battery scientifically
chance encounters with someone on the
sidewalk have completely changed
sometimes the course of my experiments
and that sort of only happens at mvl
where we get this critical mass of great
people wandering around excited to talk
about what problems they're interested
in and so it's an addiction but I think
it's a healthy addiction the MBL is some
sort of magical magnet that draws the
best and some of the best and most
interesting scientists from around the
world and it's so in some sense the
crossroads but is really a destination
it's a place where lots of people come
together from different places and just
for the summer months assemble labs and
interact as colleagues I like coming
here because it's a way to kind of just
get away from the everyday things that
are pulling on you and try new things
and there are people here to try new
things with and there's equipment here
to try new things with so it's a way to
explore wild ideas kind of spend a
couple of weeks and see if you can get
them to work and you would never make
the time to do that in your everyday
life at your everyday institution
another thing is that this is a place to
play and what I mean by that is that
science really is about curiosity and
investigating things because you find
them interesting and our lives at home
are often colored by a completely
different considerations so every summer
we come here and we try stuff it's an
invigorating exciting place it's got all
kinds of great people great equipment
and I'm reminded of a quote from
Sherlock Holmes where he said that when
you rule out the impossible whatever
remains no matter how improbable must be
the truth and so you come to and be able
to try the impossible and it's a short
time sometimes that you the impossible
works and that's what's cool about this
place is it you can try it and you can
go away and carry on with other things
or you get new ideas and it's just it's
just the place to try and have fun but
here creative students hard-working
loads of equipment and lots of reagents
mean that you can try lots of things
iterate and eventually find the solution
to the problem there's something really
wonderful about an atmosphere where you
try to do things just because you're
curious about them just because you've
been wanting to try something out you're
not worried about whether or not it'll
quote-unquote work or won't work
necessarily you just want to see what
will happen but you can you can easily
get out of your comfort zone and and you
know you can think of the crazies
experiment and if if more less you can
put it together people will help you do
it eh so I think that really gave me a
lot of confidence I needed inspired in
me a little bit of the of the office
fear like let's just go for it you know
like when you have an idea okay so how
can I get it to work let's just give it
a try I don't know of anywhere more
magical and so even though it's
certainly true that people like me
they're a little bit older should should
come here you know I I would say that
the bottom line is that this is a rite
of passage you know for students here's
a test if you see anyone who has taken a
course at the MBL overdone summer
research here taking the physiology
course say I just mentioned the word mvl
to the more the word Woods Hole and see
if they don't get kind of a misty
faraway look in their eyes and start
talking about the magic of the place
they'll start to sound a little bit like
maybe of some sort of religious fanatic
talking about a cult maybe if you
haven't been here that might be what
they sound like but if you have been
here it will sound more like an
expatriate talking about their homeland
you know a place where they feel some
deep connection to to the to what
they're doing
you